hello my name is bradley and today i
want to ask you a question
what do wine fine art and the blockchain
have in common
they're all really useful for laundering
money so i've already told you about how
to move 80 million dollars in dirty
money through offshore companies in the
last video
but i didn't answer the most important
question how do you actually get this
dirty money into your back pocket
well today i'm going to talk about
exactly that
[Music]
now in 2014 i actually purchased this
watercolor of venice while i was on
holiday now the street artist who
actually painted this wanted around 30
euros for it
now much more recently i decided to
actually see how much this painting is
worth
and it turns out that similar
watercolors by the same artist
giovanni bonazzen i think are now worth
between
500 and 800 euros so at least 10 times
more
than this was actually worth back in
2014. the key difference here
is that art is subjective and as such
there's no
fixed price for art rather it's strictly
based on
an agreement between the buyer and the
seller now this
allows for the prices of artworks to be
increased dramatically without any legal
repercussions so let's say i wanted to
sell this beautiful venetian watercolor
fortunately i have many options to do so
including ebay
or marketplaces like artsy.net or
artfinder.com
and i could also sell this piece through
a small art gallery for instance
let's say i've got an offshore account
full of dirty cash that needs laundering
what i can actually do is submit this
artwork to
auction and bid on it to artificially
inflate its price ten times over
and then actually purchase it back from
myself at this inflated price
now the beauty of this method is that
i'm not using some well-known piece of
artwork that maybe would
attract the attention of various experts
but rather i'm using a
watercolor that was painted by some
little known
street painter from venice now a
drawback of this method is that i won't
be able to use
any of those big auction houses like
sotheby's or christie's as they only
really deal with well-known artworks
if i genuinely wanted to launder a large
amount of money through the art world
i'd probably need to go big more
specifically i need to do something
exactly like matthew greene did now
matthew greene was the owner of a
mayfair
fine art gallery and he was busted in
2018 for faking the sale
of a painting supposedly painted by the
infamous pablo picasso
now this deal was set to launder around
6.7 million pounds in dirty funds
acquired by a shady stock broker
beaufort securities
now it's important to remember that this
was anything but an isolated incident
i mean according to un statistics the
global art rate is worth around 67
billion dollars
three billion of which is tied up in
money laundering and other financial
crimes
until not long ago the art trade was
completely unregulated and as recently
as 2020
anonymous buyers offshore accounts and
large cash transactions
rule the norm in this business
let's move on to talk about freeport
versus five amld
now to combat financial crime in this
sphere the eu adopted the fifth
anti-money laundering directive
or five amld as i said in 2018.
now critically this directive brought
the art trade into the scope of
stringent money laundering regulations
now since january of 2020 art galleries
and auction houses worldwide
have to report on transactions that take
place above 10 000 euros just like banks
and other financial institutions
therefore you'll probably find many
great works of art that are stored
inside these free ports the term
freeport derives from the neutral
territories where pirates used to divide
and trade their plunder now for a long
time the existence of freeports was a
well-kept secret
and freeports were recently drawn into
the public eye through the hollywood
film
tenets i'm not sure if you've seen that
now in theory these are storage units
for goods that are in transit
and therefore they're exempt from taxes
and duties
however the period in which these goods
are in transit
can theoretically last forever
so these free ports have essentially
become depositories for the elite
some of these don't even look like
storage units at all
like this one in luxembourg
either way this is one way that the art
collectors avoid paying taxes and duties
very cleverly now if we take the
freeport of geneva as an example the
total cost of goods stored there
is estimated to be worth over 100
billion dollars
i mean this stuff includes paintings
sculptures precious metals and wine
yeah so wine collecting is actually a
pretty big deal
and it's also another very clever way to
launder money
why are financial criminals starting to
prefer wine over
art well first of all those who own the
most expensive
kinds of wine in the world don't
actually need to prove where they got
their hands on it
i mean you could always say that the
bottle of 1945 petrus
it was found in your grandmother's
basement and was hidden away for decades
now you've found it and you'd like to
sell it i mean it would be difficult to
prove that you were lying in this
scenario
because nobody's really going to ask for
documentation as to how you ended up
with this bottle
second of all why is actually a lot
easier to counterfeit than you might
actually think
and this can then be sold on at auctions
on this topic let's introduce another
gentleman by the name of rudy kuniakwen
rudy entered the los angeles wine scene
back in 2003 and he was basically
presenting himself as a seasoned
wine expert with a wealthy indonesian
background at first
rudy brought up californian pinot noir
but then switched to acquiring elite
burgundy wines which actually earned him
the nickname dr quanti
as he acquired a number of bottles from
domaine de la romaine quantity
one of the most expensive wine producers
in the world now
at one point rudy admitted that he spent
over one million dollars
a month on wine purchases mad
so basically rudy lived the high life i
mean he was throwing lavish parties with
a-list hollywood movie stars and
even treated his guests to these
absurdly expensive wines
so over the years he eventually earned
the reputation of a true wine expert
and he soon started participating in
these
wine auctions as a seller rather than
just a buyer
and so rudy one by one started selling
off
his wine collection live is good life is
good
life is good so by 2006 rudy had managed
to sell about 2 000
bottles for a grand total 35 million
dollars
but the thing is almost all of this wine
was fake rudy would actually dilute the
expensive wines with cheaper stuff
in his very own kitchen and actually
used copies of labels to fool
buyers now for the casual wine
connoisseur
these fakes were actually quite
difficult to spot he could figure out
how to find the bottles with other
things
of other wines and bring them together
to recreate the taste
of the wine that doesn't exist so i
think
he was quite a genius but to full
auction houses rudy had to be a bit
smarter and so he would actually pour
his diluted concoctions into real
wine bottles and since auction houses
only really look at the exterior of
these bottles
this allowed rudy to really get away
with this scheme and
by the way the new corks on these
bottles didn't really worry the
inspectors
as over time corks disintegrate and
therefore they need replacing it's quite
common with very very old wines
that have very new corks by the way this
actually isn't that difficult to pull
off yourself i mean just google
empty petrous wine bottle and you'll see
dozens of listings
i mean these range from say 150 dollars
to
400 depending on the year and condition
but the point is
these are available to anyone and then
all you have to do is simply find
a color of wine that's similar to
appearance as the petrous wine
and cork it voila your new bottle of
petrus
is ready to go to auction and you can
actually put this onto auction
buy it back from yourself and in the
process you can launder
a considerable sum of money now this way
you can effectively turn an empty 150
bottle of nothing into a bottle of
1945 petrus that might sell for four or
five thousand pounds
that's quite special now unsurprisingly
so rudy konawan's scheme was eventually
uncovered by the authorities and it
turned out that
rudy had actually hailed from a poor
family he came to the u.s to study as an
accountant and then actually remained in
the country in violation of his visa
now in 2014 rudy was sentenced to 10
years in prison
but in april of 2021 he was released
early and deported straight back to
indonesia
but in light of rudy's scheme elite
restaurants have actually begun
destroying empty bottles in front of
diners
right now still it's unclear to what
extent
fake wines are being used to launder
money today i mean after all rudy canal
and was
just one fraudster yet the damage he
inflicted on the wine world was immense
now it goes without saying that you need
at least some wine knowledge to sell
fake bottles and actually get away with
it
um this is a white i mean what about a
money laundering scheme that uses
modern technology one that lets you
create unique digital artworks that you
can sell to yourself
without even getting up from your
computer i'm talking about one of the
hottest trends out there
nfts now nft stands for non-fungible
token
in essence these are certifiably unique
sets of data that are stored on the
blockchain
and therefore each one of these tokens
can in no way
be replaced by another obviously this
sort of technology impacts the art rate
massively
i mean when artwork is sold as an nft
it's not the artwork itself that's being
transferred it's rather the information
of the ownership
of the nft that's being placed on the
blockchain ledger this might sound a bit
complicated if you're learning about
this for the first time
so let's take a closer look do you see
on the screen right now
no this isn't actually a video poking
fun at donald trump's loss
in the 2020 election i mean
interestingly enough this artwork was
contingent on the results of that
election
as it included a link leading to one of
two possible options
one in the case of trump's victory and
another in the case of biden's victory
the artist mike winkelmann otherwise
known as beeple
sold a crypto token attached to this
work for sixty six thousand dollars
now by february of 2021 this same token
was valued at 6.6 million dollars
anyone can view this video online of
course but there's only one
true owner whose proof of ownership is
recorded on the blockchain
finding this hard to believe i don't
blame you and the problem is this is
just the tip of the iceberg
for example on march the 11th of 2021 a
collage of 5 000
of winkelmann's works was sold at
christie's for 69
million dollars so we are in
my living room and we're watching the
closing of the auction which closes in
an
hour and 18 minutes what the hell oh
my god
[Music]
69 million i think it probably means
digital art is here to stay
now the immense prices commanded by
these digital artworks really shook up
the art world i mean hundreds of
thousands of artists decide to create
their own nfts hopefully
cashing in on this new phenomenon
so are you thinking about having a go
yourself well it's actually quite simple
i mean first of all you need to open up
a crypto wallet and buy some ethereum
is basically the cryptocurrency on which
nfts are actually built
and then you need to access a service
that allows you to create an nft
one of the easiest options here is
viarable.com
where all you have to do is just click a
create button fill out a simple form
upload your file and set your asking
pricing commissions now once you've
filled out all of these fields you can
click
create item you'll be charged a
commission for entering your work onto
the blockchain
and today this usually is around 100 but
in the near future this price
could actually get a lot higher
considering that ethereum is gaining
popularity quite rapidly
and once your artwork reaches the
decentralized database you will be able
to sell it
needless to say this is easier and much
cheaper than buying an
empty bottle of expensive wine and
transforming it into something magical
i mean now all that's left to do is just
wait for a buyer
or you yourself can buy the artwork and
launder whatever dirty funds you have
once and for all in the process
so let's sum up as you can see
technologies are constantly changing
through time but what doesn't change
however is the fact that artwork and
collectibles can be artificially
inflated in price sometimes for criminal
purposes
and moreover with the dawn of nfts it's
actually getting easier
than ever to sell things to oneself i
mean sure we can probably expect
new regulations in the near future
things that aim to tackle
cryptocurrencies and nfts and the like
but i mean in the meantime you can rest
assured that criminals will take every
opportunity to make a buck or two
this is some sub a channel on navigating
the online jungle my name is bradley and
the next video will be even more
interesting so
stay tuned
[Music]
you